c'est bien aussi de pouvoir jouer on
lisait avec nos enfants notamment
et notre spécialiste avec 100 dans la
croix est là pour nous faire découvrir
en ce qui me concerne parce que les
enfants connaissent un jeu qui
visiblement a fait un carton cet été de
quoi s'agit-il alex est bien parce
qu'alice à 6,2 château aventure il
s'agit il s'agit répétez après moi il
s'agit de château aventure ce soir je
vais dîner chez ce cher serge il s'agit
de château aventure ce soir je vais
dîner chez ce chercheur péter chez vous
on y va château aventure donc c'est mon
jeu de l'été mais c'est aussi un jeu qui
prend sa base dans le jeu de point'n
click donc les pointer cliquer en
français le stop pointer cliquer c'est
quoi alors le pointer cliquer le point
technique on va faire un petit peu
d'histoire dans les années 80 c'est le
début des jeux vidéo il a fallu six mois
dans les années 80 voilà bon à ce moment
là les jeux vidéos d'essais en même
temps que vous passez calais certains
développeurs veulent se mettre du jeu de
rôle avec le jeu vidéo ça prend la forme
à ce moment là de pages de texte auquel
on répond avec des hordes par le clavier
des ordres simples aller à utiliser tel
objet puis après dans les années 90 on a
développé graphiquement les jeux et on
se baladait dans des paysages et à ce
moment là c'était avec la souris qu'on
joue et donc on allait pointer et
cliquer soit sur des personnages pour
parler avec eux soit sur des objets pour
les utiliser ou non point technique
simple quand il est plein de jeux là
j'espère qu'on va les voir parce que
y'en a plein plein plein posé sur la
table
et voilà au moins au moins on comprend
là quand on voit tout ça voilà donc ces
années 90 c'est l'âge d'or du jeu
politique clic on a plusieurs séries
comme maniac mansion bac on voit
justement derrière nous les monkey
island qui sont des jeux voilà qui ont
marqué l'histoire conte à même d'aider
des personnages très important qu ont
participé on à steven spielberg par
exemple qui a écrit le scénario de the
dig on à benoît sokal l'auteur de bandes
dessinées que vous connaissez peut-être
qu'à adapter l'amerzone et puis qu'après
a fait sa propre série syberia qui est
absolument un bijou ludique que je
conseille à tout le monde et puis du
coup c'est encore un jeu qui par sa
simplicité parce que c'est pas besoin
d'appuyer sur trente six boutons de
manière complètement énervé non c'est
juste à la souris on la balade on clique
c'est c'est tout doux donc c'est un
c'est quelque chose c'est un jeu
qui adapté à tout le monde parfait donc
nicole samuel vous allez pouvoir jouer
avec nous aussi dans votre esprit au
moins voilà l'expliqué mois alors du
coup moi je reviens quand même assez tôt
aventure parce que on a déjà parlé avec
le rétro video game il rétro le jeu
vidéo rétro on est dans une période de
nostalgie assumer sur toute cette époque
des années 80 et donc il ya un éditeur
français
yellow qui a regroupé un collectif
d'auteurs illustrateurs qui est pour
travailler sur un jeu qui requit faisait
justement qui rendait hommage à ce genre
de jeu c'est à dire le jeu d'aventuré
très simplifiées alors en quoi ça
consiste château aventure qui est là
c'est qu'en fait il ya un joueur qui va
jouer l'ordinateur et les autres joueurs
qui peuvent être aussi nombreux qu ils
veulent donne vont donner chacun un
ordre à leur tour c'est-à-dire actionner
tel bouton parler à tel personnage est
le personnage qui va jouer le
l'ordinateur va dérouler le scénario de
cette façon là donc c'est un jouet oui
alors juste pour info c'est un jeu
coopératif
donc tout le monde gagne où tout le
monde perd d'accord et ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que on a trois sauvegardes
autre clin d'oeil aux jeux vidéos de
l'époque parce que avant d'aller piquer
son sandwich à un troll ou de sauter des
navettes spatiales sans combinaison il
faut sauvegarder parce qu'on est sûr de
voir certaines actions qui sont très
dangereuses qu'on manque pas de faire
parce que on est dans l'euphorie du
moment et donc du coup il faut utiliser
une sauvegarde
alors on fait un petit une petite partie
parce qu'à bien sûr situation l'avoir
moi je veux bien moi je fais le petit le
petit ordinateur et je vais commencer à
vous donner à vous dire l'histoire
tout ce que vous avez à faire c'est me
donner une action bienvenue à château
aventure petite musique vous êtes debout
dans une petite hutte il y à une canne à
pêche ici donc je pêche
vous ne pouvez pas pêché dans la hutte
les sorties sont sortir de la lutte donc
en gros vous avez des actions allaient à
la sortie regardez
dans la hutte où faire des choses avec
l'objet qui vous a été indiqué moi j'ai
envie de faire des choses avec l'objet
qui m'a été indiqué donc qu'est ce que
vous faites je pêche
vous ne pouvez pas pêcher ici je pense
que vous prenez la canne à pêche parce
que je pense que c'est ça et donc vous
avez une magnifique canne à pêche dans
votre inventaire maintenant si l'écurie
gym ensuite bien sûr modifie que c'est
dire c'est quand même un bout de papier
qui vaut pas grand chose mes petits
papiers vous sortez de la hutte je vous
aide un petit peu vous êtes encore un
manque et comme on dit chez nous vous
vous trouvez dans les jardins royaux
leur végétation est luxuriante monde est
content qu'on a perdu derrière samuel et
nicollin
alors sony bien un rosier
c'est ça vous apercevez aussi une lutte
les sorties sont les temps le sentier
sinueux où la hutte d'accord vous pouvez
donc interagir donnez moi un ordre
rosie losier oui donc vous observez le
rosier oui oh qu'il est beau et qu'il
sent bon le rosier il sent bon le rosie
riboud voilà je pense que vous voulez
faire ça je lui massacrer sont cueillies
rose voilà bien sûr et vous avez une
magnifique rose dans votre avant merci
bon je pense que c'est la canne à pêche
et la rose c'est un beau 10 à 12 il
yad'autres voilà il ya d'autres
histoires comme ça en fait une petite
histoire sur dur quand même une demi
heure donc on va pas pouvoir tout faire
là dans la suite dommage
ah non non mais franchement c'est
vraiment dommage en ce sens qu'elle soit
pensée sont pas extrêmement réceptifs là
dessus
toujours est il que à la fin on sauve la
princesse on obtient la magnifique
couronne on compte le nombre de points
donnez moi la couronne que j'ai donnée
sur la princesse catherine et moi
nichols est ma princesse aujourd'hui
alors là je suis ravi vraiment ça on m'a
jamais offert une comme ça que la garde
précieusement pour pâques et déjà
l'objet d'une canne à pêche on it alone
voilà
non la rose de la garde chalaronne je le
garde pour vous qui étaient avec nous
parce qu'on valait feuillet un tout
petit peu si on veut tout savoir sur ce
château aventure on va faire un tour sur
le net je pense que c'est un plein
dessus s'il faut savoir c'est que en
fait c'est un recueil des scénarii il y
en a douze très différent il ya du
fantastique de science fiction et au
super ce que vous consommez de viande
oui de vous devriez arrêter ça vous
arrange pas
voici les compos